– Gehst du gerne ins Theater?
– Eigentlich schon, aber ich hab kaum Zeit.
– Oh …
Entschuldigung, ich habe nur wiederholt.
– Ach so.
Das Thema der Lektion ist Theater?
– Kunst und Kultur.
Es geht um Literatur,
Theater und Malerei,
es geht aber auch um ...
Gedichte und Romane.
– Cool.
– Na ja …
– Du interessierst dich nicht für Kultur?
– Ich gehe ganz gerne ins Kino,
aber Theater finde ich ziemlich langweilig.
– Was ist mit Musik? Du interessierst
dich doch auch für Musik.
– Ja, total!
– Bist du schon mal auf
einem Festival gewesen?
– Nein. Aber ich möchte nächsten Sommer
unbedingt auf ein Open-Air-Festival gehen.
– Mhm.
Die Band hat abgesagt.
– Was, jetzt?
Unsere Gäste kommen schon
in ein paar Stunden.
– Ja, ich weiß.
Aber der Sänger ist krank.
– Welche Band?
– Das Restaurant hat doch
zehnjähriges Jubiläum,
und wir haben dafür eine Band bestellt.
– Jetzt haben wir kein Programm?
– So kurzfristig finden wir keinen …
Ersatz.
– Ah …
– Oh!
Nein! Nein, auf keinen Fall!
– Nico?
– [Nein]
– Komm schon.